hey buddy house but how bro welcome to
the best game of the universe we're
gonna suck this guy so [ __ ] hard you
don't even know god I hate him so much
all right Stan send the [ __ ] Dale
please
this should be in there we go ah you
have to spin so much oh I heard the skin
in my hand is redonkulous you [ __ ]
[ __ ]
Oh charge a gap suck out [ __ ] out let's
look at these other pictures by the way
that looks like it's taken straight from
an anime that looks hot as [ __ ]
yeah we could actually [ __ ] [ __ ] this
[ __ ] up [ __ ] you dad come on it was a
gallant effort [ __ ] hardest game ever
played in my life
seriously [ __ ] you [ __ ] you in your
couch you [ __ ] nuts [ __ ] you in
all your muscles that's right Oh
ah America
[ __ ] oh I feel so accomplished people
say Dark Souls is hard well they haven't
played mr. mosquito is it the mom now I
think it's a mom now
look at those gigantic mountains oh no
those are boobs Jesus Christ well I
guess if you're a body builder that's
what you get look at the beautiful
scenery I love it oh there's just
there's an Easter Egg down here
grab it
we suck in her I don't I don't feel
comfortable the wind it's not one or two
sweet spots we need to find our sweet
spots boobie life movie let's try left
movies
this is for science the only way to stop
her is to bite her titties
Oh
oh right okay
video games video games see if I knew
Japanese Kanji this would be a lot
[ __ ] easier maybe hurt Oh
ah yes not it's not your toe discretion
is the bigger part you shut the [ __ ]
[ __ ] the [ __ ] up
alright just shut the shut up alright we
know one of the sweet spots it's by the
titties so we might as well go straight
for them chatez and that's a good angle
right there someone spend a considerable
amount of time animating those boobies
great job this is I'm like decent decent
this heist to this now I'm so used to
how [ __ ] up this game is that it it
doesn't even matter anymore okay well
fight me then [ __ ] suck oh oh oh no
ha
what the [ __ ] happened
what's going on
what am i doing your boobs it's not
working whoa relax don't do it when you
want to go through ring I don't know how
I don't know [ __ ] how the hell we did
that I just [ __ ] it up real good I
hope you're in pain [ __ ] idiot welcome
to the bonus stage right Harris is about
to have a bubble bath Oh is she hell oh
they kept the soundtrack they kept the
soundtrack thank you let's why not oh
god oh god there's a timer Oh Oh
fanservice oh my god there's a duck I
can't see as much boobage hello what's
good she dead
no she's like um okay good duck can i
suck you
it's [ __ ] up real good for me I
suppose
I'm supposed to collect the hearts I did
it all wrong mom my god so hard 25
hearts we can do it damn it is so
[ __ ] hard all the training in school
did not help me for this did not prepare
me for this oh my god
are you [ __ ] kidding me - shut up
she's staring em it's so awkward yes yes
game I know I'm come on one more
are you [ __ ] kidding me I'm gonna
stab a [ __ ] where is that oh there it
is come on come on come on [ __ ] much but
don't [ __ ] this up yes
this is a special spot in Jesus Christ
woman can't you see I'm busy sucking her
okay we're gonna end it there
I hope you enjoyed whatever that was and
I hope you become a sloth that like for
flies more flies and I will say awesome
uh-huh this game is [ __ ] hardcore as
[ __ ] fight me
aah how do i I don't under what is that
oh Jesus